foreign
[Music]
come on out
let's talk about a little Nothing
Compares Catherine
um
I know that you're from Belfast yeah so
growing up in Ireland
were you fascinated with Sinead O'Connor
like how did you end up being part of
this particular project I was introduced
to Sinead by my father I was very lucky
to have a father who really admired her
and loved her music and insisted on
playing The Lion and the Cobra at Soul
Pelt as we were driving around miserable
raining Northern Ireland during the 80s
so it became just like the song track um
of my childhood really and then I became
a fan
um in my own rights um in my early teens
with her second album and as I was
saying when I introduced the film
earlier you know I really loved her
music loved everything she stood for
loved how she looked was so excited by
her but then it was very demoralized
with how she was treated you know as
soon as I kind of find her properly and
I felt that she had been you know taken
away so um it made this huge dent and
and that stuck with me really throughout
my um my you know my adult life and when
I began making films in my 20s it was
just a story that always just felt um
you know really important to me to try
and tell and I had no idea how to but I
wanted to and then I was making a short
um in 2011 for my masters I was doing a
masters at the Royal College of Art and
I had made a very strange experimental
piece called mathur which is Ours from
mother and it was starting to look at
some of the themes in the film
Catholicism and its control over the
women women in Ireland and I reached out
to her then manager Faulkner Kelly and
asked um very cheekily if I could please
get access to her stems of her music to
deconstruct for the soundtrack for this
short and and he surprisingly agreed and
um I made this film and I sent them the
film and it was finished and they then
got in touch two years later and asked
me to direct her first music video in 15
years for um her track fourth and Vine
so that was in 2013 and I got to meet
her and I got to meet The Wider team and
you know that was such a fantastic
unbelievable thing to happen but then
you know this desire to tell this story
just got even stronger and anyway I went
off and I worked in shorts and
advertising for um for the last 10 years
really and um it wasn't until early 2018
I then met the film's um co-producers
and co-writers Eleanor emptage and
Michael Marley and I finally had met my
people who were like equally as
passionate and excited by this story and
together we then went about putting uh
like a one-pager down which I then
brought to the wider team and presented
to them in early 2018 and the rest is
history I love the fact that you met her
in the way that you did and I love the
fact that this seems kind of right on
time especially with with what women are
going through in the world right now in
terms of having our rights
um challenged in and everything like
that and I was saying to you when we
were sitting in the back that I feel
like had Sinead O'Connor done what she
did then now she would be lauded and
applauded as opposed to treated the way
that she was treated and I find it very
interesting like there's a scene in the
film where she's at this Bob Dylan
concert where she was invited to sing
and they were booing her and they were
treating her less than and I just find
it so interesting that they don't do
that to guys they don't do it to guys
but they do it to women like with
example with lizzo right lizzo is
oftentimes
um called out for her embracing her body
and being Unapologetic about it and
Sinead has been Unapologetic about her
image in the media too there is this one
song that you included
um black boy or mopeds I want to talk
about the decision to include that
because it's so go in line with her
stance on racism and how she not only
stood up for women but she stood up for
people of color too she certainly did
yeah I mean I just think um it's such a
beautiful song and maybe not a song that
the masses would know but um you know
yeah as it says in the film and you know
it was a time in London and East London
where there was a lot of police
brutality I you know with with young
black men and um I think
like she always does she responds to
what she sees and feels and and puts
this beautiful song together and you
know it's yeah I mean yeah I just think
it's super powerful and you know really
maybe ahead of its time I I you know it
was 1990 I think when that song came out
and
um yeah I think she had a lot of respect
for for saying it writing it she seemed
to have a lot of respect for singers she
seemed to have a lot of respect for
Humanity she definitely had a lot of
respect for for women what she didn't
have a lot of respect for was the
hierarchy that disrespected all of those
entities so let's talk about that moment
that Infamous moment that starts out
that the film starts out with sure yeah
the one that everybody knows from
Saturday Night Live I remember seeing
that in real time and I remember
thinking oh oh girl
what did you do and I was hopeful that
it was gonna blow over like you know
like a blip on the radar that it would
blow over but it did not no how and I I
think it was really smart of you to
start the film that way because there's
a whole generation of people that don't
know who she is sure they don't know
about that moment on Saturday Night Live
they don't understand why she did that
and I just want to know from you why you
chose that moment to start the film
yeah I mean it's the Madison Square
Gardens footage I mean it's 14 days
after you know the Saturday Night Live
incident and um I don't know I just
suppose it felt so potent a kind of just
summed everything up you know here is
this 24 year old girl being invited to
perform at her Idol's birthday party
she's obviously so excited and you know
thrilled to be there and Bob Dylan is
her God and
um you know she walks on stage and as
you see she's booed and Jared and it's
it's a horror show really and for me and
and the editor McMahon
um it just felt like such a potent
moment where you can just see all of it
Crossing her face you can just see all
of that disbelief and hurt and rejection
and um yeah it just felt incredibly
potent so we wanted to I suppose teasing
the themes maybe of what's to come later
without saying too much just to give a
sense that something really
um isn't right and we're and we're going
to investigate it I suppose in the film
and then obviously we we come back full
circle and look at it in detail and she
explains um what exactly was going on
there but I think it was the moment
where everything kind of broke for her
because it was heartbreaking and you
know I don't think she ever apart from
Kris Kristofferson I don't think
anyone's ever acknowledged what happened
that night or had her back or apologized
for letting that happen and not
supporting her in any way
um yeah there's a bit of a shambles to
be honest
why do you think that as women
navigating in an artistic landscape that
we aren't given the same lead way as our
male counterparts because I'm sure that
that probably happens to you as a female
filmmaker as well yeah
she's like yeah I don't want to say that
but yeah no I mean I'm happy to say it
but yeah of course but I distinguish
Sinead I mean like obviously sexism is a
huge chunk of what's going on but I
think she explains it
really interestingly is that she's just
not a conformist so on top of being a
woman she's not a conformist and I think
that makes her quite dangerous because
she doesn't listen to anybody or take
advice from anybody or take a warning
from anybody and that makes her a bit of
a live wire that can't be controlled and
I think you know the interesting thing
with her particularly is that really
she's a counterculture artist you know
she is on you know anti-establishment
kind of culture and she's been
catapulted into this Superstar realm
where she's expected to conform and
maybe be grateful and
um you know play the game and she's no
interest
responses would be that different today
I think that's a good question I'd like
to say yes but I don't know if I mean
that I don't know I mean I think what's
fascinating
you know this was a difference you know
that's what you were saying to like you
know chiefly applauded I
know she would particularly I don't know
I mean I think
because she was such a non-conformist
and
really wouldn't play the game I think
that would start to rub for a lot of you
know a lot of Superstar artists today if
they just kept pushing back and pushing
back and pushing back I don't know I I
I'm not sure to be honest I think what
the problem for Sinead is that you know
is Wisconsin says you know if you
weren't being written about it you
weren't appearing a TV you might as well
be dead or have gone you know and I
suppose today what artists have gone to
social media and they're able to speak
for themselves or respond to things that
happened she didn't have that and you'd
hope that young artists would have more
control because that exists but um
know you know I think it's fascinating
when you do look back at these
characters and you know you're not
really interested in revision of female
histories you know I'd be interested to
see
so many you know forget any artist under
the spotlight and really go through the
archive and all of these type of TV
shows and see how they're spoken to and
see how they're treated
um I imagine it would be that pretty
picture for a lot of them to be honest
because you know you just need to Deep
dive to find uh the reality of I think
how women in the spotlight are are
treated you know it's um yeah it's not
great that's why I said what I said in
the beginning because the difference
between then and now is that we do have
social media yes and like you said
artists are able to speak on behalf of
themselves yes for example when people
were coming from for lizzo for whatever
reason and now she has an Emmy for
exactly the thing that people were you
know criticizing her for I think
nowadays artists are able to not protect
themselves but but speak out on their
own behalf without somebody speaking out
for them and having the fans and the
entities that be be able to speak
directly to them so I think if Sinead
had had that available to her which she
does now but she's not gonna why judge
that up if you don't have to you know
what I mean and though in the film she
says that she left Ireland because there
was so much backlash toward women being
individuals you know you couldn't
necessarily be an individual you
couldn't speak out you couldn't be who
you wanted to be there was almost like
this ideology that we had here in
America in the 50s that women were
supposed to do certain things and stay
in their place and not say anything and
that certainly has shifted over the
decades
um do you think that you had to leave
Ireland in order to be the filmmaker
that you wanted to be just like she had
to leave Ireland to be the artist that
she wanted to be
a question
um I left Ireland because I was in
Belfast and I was a miserable hellhole I
wanted to get Alex as quickly as humanly
possible good London
um yeah I mean I suppose I wasn't even
100 aware of the uh you know I didn't
even understand how repressed we were I
think until I got to London and then it
was like oh my God where have I come
from but um yeah I mean yeah I think a
lot of people have had to leave Ireland
to try and get anywhere but what's
really exciting and
Islands now in the top 10 was liberal
countries in the world I think it's
number seven or something absurd which
blows my mind and there's so many you
know my generation I left in the early
90s everyone's got the hell out as they
did in her generation but everyone's not
returning which also blows my mind I'm
not quite there yet maybe in 10 years
but uh there's so much happening and you
know it's kind of an exciting country to
live in no way there's you know it's we
had the evil marriage referendum in 2015
and the repeal of the earth abortion
referendum in 2018 and you know there's
been Titanic shifts and you know thank
God things are moving
in a better Direction
I'm happy to hear that
oh yeah
I was I remember going to her house and
I was literally shaking in the car
outside I was very scared this is when
2013 when I was doing the music video
but uh yeah no I I tried to play it cool
but of course I couldn't and um yeah she
was lovely you know it was just amazing
to meet her and you know tell her what
she meant to me and get to work with her
you know that early stage it was it was
a real dream to be honest so
but it really has you know it really did
set the scene for this being made as
well which I didn't realize at the time
so um you know it's been this wild
organic Journey from start to finish
well I think there's a perfect place to
wrap it up
before we go let me just remind you all
that Nothing Compares will be in
theaters this Friday at the Lemley
Monica and it then we'll be streaming on
Showtime September 30th and premiering
on show for people that have
subscriptions and then premiering on
Showtime October 2nd for everybody else
let's let's give Miss Catherine Ferguson
a big hand
my name is Sinead O'Connor I am a woman
I have something to offer
they tried to bury me
[Music]
they didn't realize I was a seed
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]